hey guys i'm ryan right no this would be
crazy we're gonna check out this video
today that i just got on our facebook
called slap her children's reactions
let's check this out
[Music]
combat economy no ego want any of it
oh no service
oh you can finally get back to my
channel for chop retire
thank you for your worst fear another
the reason it is so young okay
a Martina
[Music]
a or pandemic that itself
[ __ ]
[Music]
finally Runa pocket
[Music]
that they was careful ah [ __ ] there was
careful die do it no their children
slapper
thank you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
no no okay
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay so
[Music]
but any adult world bat that's great I
love that that was cute that was really
adorable I wonder if that was like some
weird social experiment or if that was
like a PSA like you know about not
hitting women
you know like women hit men all the time
so I feel like if you want equal
treatment you should be able to smack
the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ]
you hit me I would gladly hit you hit me
not on camera I could get sued by you
evidence let's wipe the [ __ ] out of you
when a camera camera's not rolling I'll
gladly smack the [ __ ] out of you we
might have to balance out later I might
never figure out you're just saying this
to say it or actually I'm just saying it
to say no I don't believe in hitting
woman I don't I really think it is wrong
but it's kind of a cute like childhood
message to actually give to the youth in
an adorable way because you gotta
implant it in their brain when they're
young that you cannot hit a woman like
you got to put that in their brain when
they're really young because like if a
child is exposed to a woman getting hit
in their brain like some weird
psychological processing being occurs
where they're like back of their head
it's like okay I guess depending on the
situation it might be okay to hit
someone but hearing these kids values
and morals is really cool because you
know they're saying like children don't
hit girls so that's these kids are all
very good people yeah they're all very
good people I wonder if they got any
like douche bag kids who were like you
like actually you like punch her or
something I mean I saw this video once
called man smacks the soul out of a girl
and that was a funny video it was like
very shocking cuz those girls it's got
smacked in the face but this know what
is she kind of
come in you got to watch the video no
you gotta watch the video you'll
understand but in this one you know like
you're putting it in a scenario where
they meet a random girl and it's cool
because it's cute it's adorable
you got these kids all gawking at the
same chick which is how it's gonna be in
life here's my question though and like
I was actually wondering this the entire
time it was going on why is it okay to
touch somebody without getting their
permission whether it's just you know
doing this mm-hmm or you know kissing on
the cheek right why is that okay but
it's not okay to slap somebody
well slapping is a physical painful
thing caressing as a whole other's way
there's no consent from the other person
so why is it okay to say caress her why
is that okay I'm pretty sure the girl
had some type of consent no you can
still get suited if you don't really
know the person you can still get in
trouble if I like but you know if I if I
didn't know you and I was like hey you
could still cause like sexual harassment
cases against me so but that's what I'm
saying it's like why is it okay to tell
some kid to like caress somebody else
but like why why do they make that okay
like I want to make sure these boys end
up straight and [ __ ] girls ah this is
America [ __ ] for whatever this country
is wrong anyway guys thanks for telling
me that video was out yeah it was
adorable
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Alyssa be
crazy has a channel it's been growing a
lot lately check out why Eamon fair on
Veeran hey mr. Ryan right
I was wondering for you give me a
shout-out I'm writing this comment from
a hospital bed right now I have been
very ill the past few days and your
videos are making me laugh and be less
ill uh-huh that's great I love watching
your channel keep the great videos
coming peace out bro Iman Fearon dude if
you're in the hospital right now and
you're sick there's only one thing one
thing that'll help you get through the
pain laughter is the best medicine
jacking the [ __ ] off jackoff Nasser bait
yourself whatever terminology works for
you as long as you're masturbating and
releasing that semen from your testicles
it just makes your life that much better
oxytocin is forgiving what no no don't
these are the worst advice ever I'll
tell you what have you ever masturbated
while you're sick it feels great you
have why you think that work in
hospitals families and friends sure why
because you'll know that when you do
that your heart rate goes up if you're
hooked up to a machine and your heart
rate just starts going up automatically
guess what alerts the nurses guess who
comes ready gets into the room while
you're like in the middle nurses well
that's why you know that's why you take
the needle and the things off your
fingers out of you you jerk off and you
just put her back put it back on